the ignoring his own daughter for four
years and the president United States
hanging up a stocking for the dog I mean
I'm off the grid for August but fear not
CNN is still a far left activist
organization pretending to be a
journalistic outfit but Scott Jennings
the president has made being a family
man a central part of his political
identity
uh it's not Republicans with all due
respect who made Hunter Biden into a
complete scumbag on this and other
issues the ignoring his own daughter for
four years and the president United
States hanging up a stocking for the dog
I mean and not for his seventh
grandchild we can also have something we
can also have sympathy for people who
are struggling with addiction let's keep
this conversation responsible listen
I totally agree and you know where I'm
from a lot of families deal with
addiction and you know who ends up
picking up the pieces the grandparents
and in this case the grandparents would
not acknowledge this little girl it is
offensive but the bottom line is but
they have now the pull oh what a hero
the polling must have been brutal